- [Instructor] We're told
that a certain mapping
in the xy-plane has the
following two properties.
Each point on the line y is equal to
three x minus two maps to itself.
Any point P not on the line
maps to a new point P'
in such a way that the
perpendicular bisector of
the segment PP' is the line
y is equal to three x minus two.
Which of the following statements is true?
So is this describing a
reflection, a rotation,
or a translation?
So pause this video and see
if you can work through it
on your own.
All right so let me just
try to visualize this.
So, and I'll just do a very quick,
so if that's my y-axis,
and that this right
over here is my x-axis.
Three x minus two might
look something like this.
The line three x minus two would look
something like that.
And so what we're saying is,
or what they're telling us,
is any point on this
after the transformation
maps to itself.
Now that by itself is a pretty good clue
that we're likely dealing
with a reflection.
Because remember with a reflection
you reflect over a line,
but if a point sits on the line,
well it's just gonna
continue to sit on the line.
But let's just make sure
that the second point
is consistent with it being a reflection.
So any point P not on the line,
so let's see, point P, right over here,
it maps to a new point P' in such a way
that the perpendicular bisector of PP'
is the line y equals three x minus two.
So I need to connect,
so the line
three x minus two,
y is equal to three x minus two,
would be the perpendicular bisector
of the segment between P and what?
Well let's see I'd have to
draw a perpendicular line.
It would have to have the
same length on both sides
of the line y equals three x minus two.
So P' would have to be right over there.
So once again this is consistent
with being a reflection.
P' is equidistant on the
other side of the line as P.
So I definitely feel good that this
is going to be a
reflection right over here.
Let's do another example.
So here we are told,
and I'll switch my colors up,
a certain mapping in the
plane has the following
two properties.
Point O maps to itself.
Every point V on a circle C
centered at O,
all right, maps to a new point W
on circle C
so that the counterclockwise
angle from segment OV
to OW measures 137 degrees.
So is this a reflection,
rotation, or translation?
Pause this video and try to
figure it out on your own.
All right, so let's see.
We're talking about circle
centered at O.
So let's see, let me just say,
so I have this point O.
It maps to itself on its transformation.
Now every point V on
circle C centered at O.
So let's see, let's say this is circle C
centered at point O,
so I'm gonna try to draw a
decent looking circle here.
You get the idea.
This is not the best hand-drawn
circle ever, all right.
So every point, let's
just pick a point V here.
So let's say that that is the point V,
on a circle centered at
O maps to a new point W
on the circle C.
So maybe it maps to a new point W on,
actually let me keep reading,
W on circle C so that the
counterclockwise angle
from OV to OW
measures 137 degrees.
Okay so we wanna know the angle from OV
to OW going counterclockwise
is 137 degrees.
So this right over here is 137 degrees.
And so this would be the segment OW.
W would go right over there.
And so what this looks like is well
if we're talking about angles
and we are rotating something,
this point corresponds to this point,
it's essentially the
point has been rotated
by 137 degrees
around point O.
So this right over here
is clearly a rotation.
This is a rotation.
Sometimes reading this language at first
is a little bit daunting.
It was a little bit
daunting to me when I first
(laughing) read it.
But when you actually just break it down
and you actually try to
visualize what's going on,
you'll say well okay
look they're just taking
point V and they're
rotating it by 137 degrees
around point O.
And so this would be a rotation.
Let's do one more example.
So here we are told,
so they're talking about,
again a certain mapping in the xy-plane.
Each circle O with radius r
and centered at x y is
mapped to a circle O'
with radius r and centered at x plus 11
and then y minus seven.
So once again pause this
video, what is this?
Reflection, rotation, or translation?
All right so you might be tempted,
if they're talking about circles
like we did in the last example,
maybe they're talking about a rotation.
But look, what they're really saying is,
is that if I have a circle,
let's say I have a circle right over here,
centered right over here.
After it, so this is x comma y,
centered at x comma y.
It's mapped to a new circle
O' with the same radius.
So if this is the radius,
it's mapped to a new circle
with the same radius,
but now it is centered at,
now it is centered at x plus 11,
so our new x-coordinate
is gonna be 11 larger,
x plus 11, and our y-coordinate
is gonna be seven less.
But we have the exact same radius.
We have the exact same radius.
So our circle would still,
so we have the exact same
radius right over here.
So what just happened to the circle?
Well we kept the radius the same,
and we just shifted,
we just shifted our center
to the right by 11,
plus 11, and we shifted it down by seven.
We shifted it down by seven.
So this is clearly a translation.
So we would select that right over there.
And we're done.